Chào măng, Ibran, International Giãn, Cương 1, Tinh Truyết, ông Mú Taba Khamay này, con trai cô lắng tủ Ali Khamay này đã được lựa trọn làm lắng tủ tuối cao.
Chúng tôi bỏ phía, người mừng bắt thăm ba của hội đồng trinh ra của ông tảm vi cám thình viên.
Theo các quan chức ông Mú Taba Khamay này được lựa vệ bình kinh mạnh Ibran ủng hộ nhờ kinh nghiệm của Ali, các bộ mấy em niên và của sử.
Ông Mú Taba điều hành phòng lắng tủ tuối cao, giữ vị thế ai chết tôi là,
của quan hệ mật thiết với lực lượng vệ bình kinh mạnh của sao Ibran ủ sê, và lực lượng dân quân bà sì,
đồng thời kiểm soát nhiều tài sản tại chính quan trọng.
Dù chưa dự chứ vô chính tinh nào trong chính quyền, ông có hình hưởng gắn cây thằng sau hổ chường vòng hộ chủy bảo thủ cứ sáng vô chá mình.
Mò ra chính khủy răng cũng sân nhận, vâng mẹ và mô con trai gó mù ta bà đã thiệt mạnh trong các cuộc tấn công.
Chuy đào các mồn tình cũng cho biết, cậu nghe thư thế cô lắng tủ khamay này còn còn những tư tưởng ôn hoa,
như giáu sĩ Alirisa Arafi và trong nội lắng tủ rung là khu mini.
Strayed Hasan khu mini, khu mini, khu mini sương áp yên mô không tích toàn nhà của đồng truyền xa tại quân.
Mù sô báo cáo chơi sang của tấn công nhằm cảnh trở tính chính lợi trọng lãnh đạo mới,
tuy nhiên hẳng tình phá sách nhận không có phiên học chức tếm nào sĩnh xa tại thư điểm đó, zor lâu ngài ăn ninh.